so my title of the talk is a bit generic
so it's advanced compilation topics so
and it's even more generic the abstract
but I want to talk about some features
that people ask can you do this and you
know can you do that with a compiler
that might be I can be able to answer
them and then also Tom will give a demo
at the end talking about that so
remember like what Tom showed which is
you know the the compiler is like a
layered system where you have some move
from language we translate that into
some ast that then we do you know these
macro system expansion analysis closure
analysis so the some of those were you
know kind of used by Brenton
we then converted into the slow form you
know intermediate representation or I
should say one thing so one thing is the
compiler that the stuff that I'm talking
about is not really for you know like
generic users it's more like oh you know
what's it what's inside how does it work
or how can you use it to do whatever you
want to work so you know some of this
stuff maybe you know if you know if
you're happy with function you know with
Mathematica not using a compiler that's
fine but this is more how to develop and
build on top of the compiler so after we
do this on type I R we do type inference
just a big chunk of our kind of
technology then we do like function
resolution and and other optimizations
and then we generate you know LLVM or
c++ you know we have this Wolfram
runtime library that we need which mark
talks about and then also then we
finally generates CPU or web assembly
and we're in the work of generating GPU
and FPGA there's a few challenges for
that but the most important thing is
this extendable so at any point you can
add extra kind of components and then
you can just weave them in into the
system so so even in the language part
so essentially like you know kind of
what
Brenton was talking about he defined
this it's like redefine what derivative
means you can think of that as a
different language from the Wolfram
language you're still writing most of
the stuff in Wolfram language but
derivative of one means something
different but but that's kind of what we
do is we we extend it so and a lot of
these components are independent and
then we don't want the type inference
even in the type inference what we do is
you know we have some default type of
environment and then we do some analysis
we do you know we look at the Wolfram we
look at the program we generate lists of
constraints we solve them and then kind
of resolve some functions but even
within that we are able to essentially
do to add user type environments so or
override certain types that are in in in
the system so this kind of is important
like for example if you're if you want
to if you're on a xat you know a 64-bit
machine and you want a cross compile to
Raspberry Pi or you want to cross
compile to you know a 32-bit system
you'd use a you know you'd either use a
different default type environment or
you know you define your own type
environment or maybe you need Plus to be
you know means something different then
you could just redefine what plus means
and you don't need to use you know like
down values or whatever so what this
talk is about is essentially how to
extend the system by adding other
languages support and other external
libraries I'm not going to talk about
the other stuff the you know if you're
interested we can talk later so I think
that's
so so for that I need to go to a right
so I don't think I need to let's see
so for that let me just kind of so and
you need this thing actually can
everybody see I mean I think it's
probably right this is better so in in
this function I have like there's some
program and I'm just extending the so
first of all you can say compiled
program you don't have to compile won't
function and compiled program would
allow you to define external functions
or define multi functions but here I'm
defining okay what is a I'm defining two
functions one is called C backtick
malloc so this is you know malloc and
see this is essentially you know how
you'd call Lib C so you know I'm
defining a seed backtick malloc and the
actual name of it is really malloc this
is kind of like a mathematical form of
it are giving some context and I'm also
defining a native primitive function C
free which you know it's you know you
can use it but then you could do
essentially you know you know use these
free within your program so yeah I'm
allocating have some program that takes
some size it allocates that size and
then you know it casts that information
into an array because malloc returns a
void void star so you need to do this
casting and then I'm accessing the first
element which is undefined bit but it's
okay and then I free it so so I can do
that I can compile it and I can generate
some code and actually like probably
every time you call this it's gonna you
can generate any value so so essentially
you know if you want to program C but
within Mathematica you know you could
you could do that you could do more
fancy stuff you know like for example
you can have a function called a lock
which does a you know it doesn't malloc
and then a free which performs a free
and then a set element which takes a you
know a pointer a position and the value
and then sets that and obviously you can
do this polymorphically so that you know
you could put in any value at any index
and then I get element function so in
here I can allocate five elements I get
a pointer I can set the second position
to one and I can get that back so
essentially now I'm escaping to C now
this is quite useful in a lot of cases
you know primarily if you just kind of
want to write C or you know you're
generating your kind of generating C on
the flier code like that you can
actually do that in this language so the
other thing that yeah it's the operating
system so there's other interesting
things so which is you can integrate
with other languages that generate LVM
ir so we're kind of built on top of well
we could use LLVM ir so we can leverage
a you know programming languages that
actually generates LVM ir so one popular
example is rust so i'm here gonna define
like some code that generates some LOV
mir and i'm gonna have a rust program so
so I'm going to just define that and
this is a string you know VM string is
some string of you know some string of
data
but then I can put in that string
directly into my program so I can say
LVM string you know that variable and
then I can use that so I define in here
I defined a whoops in in in in in here i
defined a square function so i can use
that from within my code so i'm going to
call the square with some argument which
is a real 64 and whenever I call that I
can get you know but essentially you can
have a if you have a famous rust library
or you know some framework or whatever
you could do that right the interest
the other interesting thing is the
ability to compile or use C++ code
within your your program so here are the
same idea you know you compile to using
clang to LV Mir and in here I'm defining
another square function and that square
function you know it's just there but I
can use it in the same way I would nor
this error message I think you know I
need to set a flag or something to
disable that but you know essentially I
put in that lbm string and then I can
again use it so that's great now you can
define more complicated functions so in
here I have a function that's a mean so
this is also like you know you don't
need to use vibrate link any of that
sort of stuff you know you can just use
C strings directly in your program but
you know here I'm defining a mean that
just averages the values and again I can
I can essentially you know the this mean
function takes a packed array of real 64
you do need to do some of these casting
but I think those are you know can be
simplified later on and this code you
know the the LVM string is you know some
sort of you know has likely loops and
stuff like that
and I can call it and I can compare
that against you know a the mathematical
mean function so here I have a compiled
function so this is essentially calling
the compiled C code so the compile
function is you know you know 2x or
whatever slower than then the mean
function in Mathematica so I can be more
fancy for example I can use Cindy
so sim D is just vector instructions and
I can use this library called XMD to use
that so this is a bit more complicated
code but I can bind that you know you
can embed that in this code didn't
change and so it generates you know a
lot more code but when I evaluate that
on the you know system you know on the
system I'd get you know you know
something closer to Mathematica is
implementation Mathematica uses you know
sim D and you know power programming so
it would get that's why we'd gets more
speed up so kind of close to this so the
other thing that people ask is like oh
yeah if only I had C++ 17 I can do this
sort of stuff only so this is using C++
20 which is not so and it's essentially
similar to what
brenton was doing is just kind of
leveraging C++ but essentially I have
this regular expression which recognizes
dates you know year-month-day and it
generates a and any generate a composite
regular expression at compile time
so it's leveraging C++ compile time
features use constant exper they're
called and it generates like a you know
a slew of code a lot of code right but I
can use that you know I don't have to
rewrite you know stuff manually so then
I have a thing that says
you know recognized a you know I can
call this is date function right so if I
pass it in a string which is 2018 827 it
returns true if I return it if I pass it
in - you know it returns false so
finally I thought you know like kind of
what
Brenton was talking about there was an
internal discussion like because he was
using those tools the static analysis
and figured out oh there's some
inefficiencies in some of the algorithms
so I thought it would be nice to have a
fast data structure in in in in
Mathematica which is something that's a
bit higher so so a common thing that we
need to do in the compiler is to do
Union and intersection operations and
those are efficiently implemented in a
thing called a data structure called bit
vector so we can define some you know
kind of you know common operations like
bit vector create big vector you know
create full is really like just set all
the elements to one you know turn off a
certain element or turn you know toggle
and a certain element do a union
operation do an intersection operation
you know check if something is set so
then once I have those functions I can
define some wrapper code so you know
just kind of make stuff pretty like make
boxes and and things like that
and then I can use it so let's say I
have a bit vector which is Apple oranges
you know some fruits and then I can
remove orange so in here you know this
this thing had orange element this thing
no longer has it and then I can create
another vector which is actually the
original one and then I could do the
intersection of the two and it's like
orange is no longer there so yeah so I
mean I could go in you can use any of
the kind of
any library that's in C++ or C the other
thing that I thought was interesting was
I started working on adding sim D
support for the compiler so it ends up
like not you know so essentially you you
could define what you know you could
define a new structure called like a
vector you know a sim D vector so a
short vector kind of instruction and
give it the size and you essentially can
define overload what plus and times and
things like that mean and call directly
into the intrinsic c you know x86 or you
know wherever arm intrinsic to do the
vector operations and essentially if you
do that then you know first of all you
generate you know efficient code but
also you could generate results this is
a four by four matrix multiplication but
you can generate performance that's
similar to intel's performance for those
operations now but essentially we're
writing stuff in top level they're
writing stuff in assembly so that's kind
of the main difference when they have
all knowledge that we don't have so I
think I'll stop here